l'objectif est riche à moitié parce
qu'on souhaitait surtout aborder le
match retour avec un avantage on a un
réel avantage soit faudra faudra en
profiter surtout ne pas aborder le match
retour en voulant préserver un soir
attention je pense pas qu'on soit une
équipe qui sache le faire les allemands
dont on va aller qu'on joue notre
football
quand je fais un bon match comme ce soir
et puis surtout en profitant notre
avantage
personnellement vous étiez bien aussi
ben tout le monde je pense que toute
l'équipe a fait un bon match après j'ai
la chance eux d'arrêter un penalty qui
préserve le qui préserve notre but parce
qu'on voulait surtout ne pas encaisser
de but à domicile parce qu'on sait que
ça que ça compte double sur les matches
aller retour donc maintenant c'est bien
on est sur une série de deux matchs
prolonger au maximum on le sait un
rapidement qu'il ya un gros match qui
arrive c'est la samaritaine
est ce que c'est le capital confiance
qu'on avait besoin aussi à vendre de ce
calibre mais je pense que c'est un match
entre guillemets référence après donc
dans le contenu du match c'est ce qu'on
est habitué à faire chaque semaine
maintenant on a eu on a réussi à
concrétiser nos occasions ce week-end
sur ce match là et après la somme ait
avant la samaritaine et un match très
important de championnat il sera
compliqué aussi contre le seo tv samedi
donc ces matches là c'est sûr vont nous
emmener jusqu au majorat samaritaine et
puis là c'est un match aussi à
élimination directe donc il faudra être
prêt surtout contre pour l'instant la
mieux qu'ils peuvent de lille donc on va
essayer de faire mon match de se mettre
au niveau et puis de les embêter au
maximum